[Applause]
and i do hereby declare that louis
thomas french is duly elected as the
member of parliament for old bexley and
syd cup
relief for the tories after they held
this by-election in southeast london
with a majority over labour of just
under four and a half thousand
old bexley and sibcup's new mp his local
councillor louis french i'm absolutely
delighted to become the first homegrown
mp for our local area uh it's been it's
a great privilege you know i'm deeply
honored to be wearing the the ribbon of
james broken shoe my late friend i was
asked by the family to do that it's a
great one to be doing so you know to get
over 50 of the vote in a in a december
election you know by election with the
government in place you know it's a
great result for us and we're absolutely
delighted with the result on a low
turnout of just 34
the conservatives majority was slashed
from 19 000.
the tory share of the vote was down 13
and labors was up seven and a half
percent this is the seat that has always
been uh tory stronghold it's the tory at
heartland and actually what we've seen
tonight is a swing to labor of over uh
10
and you know that's a that's a great
result for us in in tory in tory
heartland
labour fought this by-election focusing
on allegations of tory sleaze and the
personal conduct of boris johnson
the conservatives will be mightily
relieved to have got this by-election
out of the way albeit with a reduced
majority and reduced share of the vote
all the parties have made a quick get
away from old bexley and syd cup that's
because the by-election roadshow moves
on to north shropshire in two weeks time
and that could be a much tougher battle
for the tories
here in south east london the
by-election was caused by the death of a
much-loved local mp james brokenshire
shropshire north however will be fought
against the background of former mp owen
patterson's breach of commons rules and
allegations of mps for hire
john craig sky news south east london